[Music]
adriana you just won the game against
the leader of the tournament elires
ferruja how important this victory is
for you
yeah it's very good of course um i mean
it's still the start of the tournament
but it was a gift uh this is
a rare week moment for our ali reza i
mean he after the opening things just
went very badly
um
i guess he was experimenting a bit with
a playable line but
um d4 immediately is not the way to play
it
and then things i don't know if he
overlooked to take c3 but soon he was
down upon for no compensation
i think i even had uh
let's say the pun and i had the
compensation because i also had a good
good position on top of that
and then he went for an exchange
sacrifice which was very desperate
but i understand that he was um
hoping that at least my king is weak and
he can start an attack
but i i think this was quite accurate
how i played it with bishop takes f2
especially
and this one was really nice actually
did you count everything in india yeah
yeah it's uh it's i don't know if it's
necessary but i didn't see anything else
which was clear because rookie seven
looks like a huge mess to me and bishop
takes up two is very forcing if he takes
it then his king gets uh
into the attack or if he takes with the
rook then his attack uh finishes on the
king's side and he's left simply down in
exchange in a few pawns and the problem
with this king on the h file is that
even though he wins my queen
uh he starts to get mated because his
king is is stuck there and my works will
come to the h5 file very quickly so
after that it was it was very easy yeah
you won the game the first game of this
tournament the how was the yesterday it
felt that you couldn't still find your
way
yeah yesterday i played quite poorly
i had chances for sure
um i think in the first round against
sam although i was also close to losing
or maybe just losing i also had good
chances to win
um second game was unfortunate jeffrey
came super well prepared and
uh still i had some chances to draw the
game at the end a total miracle
and and then in the last game against
jan i also had some chances to win
but overall my play wasn't good so i
i can't even be upset that it was only
minus one because i think it could have
been worse with how i played yeah but
now okay
when you are
in the 50
at the moment so with which result you
will be happy in this tournament
i i don't know i mean a plus four would
be good um i think i would be happy with
the plus score because then that puts me
in at least a i think anyone who has a
plus core has a good chance to fight for
for the top places in the blitz um
because that's where the majority of the
ups and downs are usually and you see a
lot of leaders shifting
but usually the players who score well
in the rapid are
you know usually finished among the top
yeah so here we are in the saint louis
chess club on the background you can see
the chess boards and everything so how
does it feel to play home
it's it's good i was traveling a huge
amount um
the olympiad left the candidates and
and all sorts of tournaments in between
before that
uh so it's good to be back and the last
tournament i played here i had a big
success uh so
hopefully i can continue yeah we wish
you all the best of luck again in the
next rounds thank you
fight